[Music]
today for our daily cancellation
we must discuss mr potato head or rather
potato head um
we must not dead name potato head by
calling a mr potato
any longer according to numerous reports
on thursday
hasbro was said to be to be dropping the
mister in order to make potato head
gender-neutral
kimberly boyd the senior vice president
of global brands at hasbro
explained the move saying culture has
evolved
kids want to be able to represent their
own experiences the way the brand
currently exists with the mr and mrs is
limiting when it comes to both gender
identity and family structure
the website fast company which
interviewed boyd went to more detail
saying
this mean the toys this means the toys
don't impose a fixed notion of gender
identity or expression
freeing kids to do whatever feels most
naturally to them a girl potato might
might want to wear pants a boy potato
might wear earrings
hasbro will also sell box sets that
don't present a normative family
structure
this approach is clever because it
allows kids to project their own ideas
about gender sexuality and family onto
the toy
without necessarily offending parents
that have more conservative notions
about family
well yes we cannot force this outmoded
idea of mother and father potato heads
onto kids onto society
some children may want a potato family
with two mom potatoes or two dad
potatoes or
three mom potatoes a dad potato a
chicken sandwich in order to have the
full value meal
these are the choices that children must
be able to make this is the world
that children deserve to live in a world
with transgender potatoes
homosexual potatoes pansexual potatoes
bisexual potatoes why can't the potato
be polyamorous bisexual tri-gendered and
sometimes
dabble in a little bdsm these are all
valid expressions
valid identities and they deserve to be
represented
and that's why today i did not
originally intend to cancel hasbro or
potato head
i was going to cancel all of those all
of you who are mocking this move calling
it silly superficial ridiculous woke
virtue signaling and so on
i mean you are canceled for your lack of
a progressive world view
for your lack of appreciation and
respect for the lived experience of
gender fluid potatoes
those of us with a more enlightened
outlook saw the potato news for the
landmark occasion that it was or
we thought that it was this story has a
twisted and tragic ending but before we
get there
i just want you to understand what this
meant to me and my family
in fact i'll never forget this i i told
my seven-year-old daughter
about the potahto head news yesterday i
came into the living room she was
sitting at the table
drawing a picture of greta thunberg and
i turned to her and i said listen
addison i need to tell you something and
she looked at me and she was a little
concerned
and she said what is it father and i
took a deep breath and i said
it's happened it's finally happened
mr potato head has come out as gender
fluid
now always remember the look on her face
she was shocked at first
but then a smile spread quietly across
her face and she started to tear up
and she said finally i had been waiting
for this day my entire life
now i can be at peace and we just hugged
each other and sobbed it was it was
beautiful
and there were so many conversations
just like this across the country a
great burden
had been lifted now admittedly there was
still so much work to do mr peanut mr
clean
many fictional characters must still be
freed from their gender binary prison
mr pibb most of all pibb is already a
fluid
yet we bottle it both physically and
metaphorically
and force pig to live a lie but progress
takes time
and we were taking the first step at
least that's how it seemed
then later on thursday in the midst of
the jubilation
came the crushing blow hasbro sent out
another tweet with their with the from
their official account
saying quote hold that top your main
spud mr potato head isn't going anywhere
well it was announced today that the
potato head brand name and logo are
dropping the mister
i am proud to confirm that mr and mrs
potato head
aren't going anywhere and will remain mr
and mrs potato head
devastating and for hasbro to be so
flippant
making potato puns in the midst of a
great national crisis like this
is unconscionable one minute i thought
that bigotry had been defeated that the
patriarchy dismantled
transphobia annihilated the next we're
back in our oppressive reality
with plastic potatoes that uphold the
gender binary
i'll never forget breaking the news to
my daughter i went back into the living
room
found her cradling her potato head in
her arms whispering you're free my child
you're free and i sat her down and i
said addison
a tragedy has just occurred
the potato head is still a man
hasbro duped you they duped all of us
and i broke down and i wept and addison
threw the potato across the room
began to kick me violently saying father
you lied to me you lied to me you scum
all i could do was apologize and plead
with her it was no use
i knew her life was ruined and so was
mine
so it was a roller coaster day it ended
by careening off the tracks and there
were no survivors emotionally
and that's why hasbro is in the end
cancelled
mr potato head is canceled and all of
you who would mock our pain
or our joy before the pain are also
canceled
how dare you how dare all of you
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated